how many people watching this review
remember those old final fantasy tactics
games the one that on the ps1 then they
went to like the game boy right with
advance and advanced two you guys know
where i'm going with this any type of
gameplay that even remotely goes into
this type of game automatically has my
attention and got another one for you
guys man it's actually made by the
people who made octopath traveler it's
called triangle strategy and i'm gonna
review it today i played it on the
nintendo switch took me about 70 hours
to beat that's right
70 hours then it took me a minute to
beat this game and i want to go over
everything that i learned about triangle
strategy in the 70 hours it took to beat
it but before we get on with the review
you guys know how it is definitely that
like button if you guys enjoyed the
video and you can always subscribe to
the channel we do weekly podcasts at 1pm
and without any further ado here's my
review on triangle strategy for the
nintendo switch
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord act here
coming at you for another review today
we're going to be reviewing triangle
strategy for the nintendo switch now
let's give it a little bit of backstory
when it comes to me and these type of
games
i grew up on a lot of final fantasy
games and final fantasy has a special
place in my heart for the most part the
older ones but there was always one
particular final fantasy game that
imprinted on my soul and that was final
fantasy tack i have beat this game so
many times so when i go to see a game
that has similar type of gameplay on it
automatically catches my eye when i saw
his triangle strategy a few months ago i
was like yo that is definitely looking
like some kind of spiritual successor to
final fantasy tactics i need that in my
life so obviously when this game came
out your boy had to grab it man you know
so we're reviewing it and playing it and
i noticed that there is some stuff the
first thing we're going to talk about is
the performance and the graphics
performance on this i can't really i
can't sugarcoat it now look was the
performance horrible no i'm not gonna
come out here and say that it was
unplayable or anything like that for the
most part even though that the
performance was a little bit on the
lackluster side it is kind of a
turn-based grid style game so it's not
like the performance had to be all there
it's not like it was like some quick
reflex type of game like eldon ring or
something so that really helped it run
on the switch where i wasn't really
aggravated too much on it but i do want
you guys to know that i personally
myself felt a lot of stuttering with
this game i felt you know sometimes the
loading took a little bit too long that
i'm willing to sit through but i did it
because it is the switch and i enjoy
this type of gameplay let's talk about
the the graphics and kind of the art
style i actually felt like triangle
strategy did a very good job and the
people who made this
that this kind of art style is not going
to go away anytime soon five years from
now people are still going to remember
this game because of the unique art
style that they had and i'm really
grateful that they kind of went for this
not mainly like a realistic approach
because when it comes to this type of
art style it's like i said it lives up
years down the line and now is it going
to look pretty five years from now no
the animations definitely are going to
get passed up but when you look at the
vibrant colors and the way that the
world really interacts especially with
the music you know we'll get into the
music a little bit later but all of
these
variables come together and they give
you this really immersive experience
now
let's talk about the animations that i
brought up earlier now look there is
some gameplay mechanics i'll go over
later on the video where it's pretty
much like
you interact a lot with the animations
because stuff is always going on
depending on what you do in combat and i
feel like they did these animations
really well i felt like the ice looked
really good on here fire looked really
good and the lightning looked good like
they have a lot of elemental animations
on here that i feel maybe isn't top key
but considering what type of game this
is it looked really nice when it was
happening and i don't really have
anything bad to say about them
especially the world that they built the
graphics that went into it the music
went into it it all came together to
make a very cohesive
kind of great story like look you can
nitpick certain things that happen on
this story but i don't think you could
ever go out and say this story's bad i
felt like this story is like a game of
thrones type of story that there is
always something on the line type of
story and i really enjoyed what was
going on with it now they had very good
supporting characters they had
characters that's kind of like a mentor
state and they had characters that you
look at that you know for a fact there's
gonna be beef in the future but it's
okay because the way they told the story
and the way the story unfolded made
sense nothing was
out of chance like they put everything
in here for a specific reason there's
branching paths in this game think of a
little bit like mass effect now
obviously nothing too dramatic is mass
effect but i will say that the branching
paths do matter and what i mean by they
matter is you'll go through this
kind of state where you have to talk to
all the people that's there you have to
get their input on stuff and you never
do anything by yourself let me emphasize
on that it's very annoying sometimes and
it's not necessarily like a nitpick on
the game that's how good they did it
where i actually felt something on the
line when i'm going to do these scale
things and what the scale mechanic in
the game is is the main people in your
team all get a vote and you have to go
around and convince them that you need
to go do this instead of that or do that
instead of this
keep in mind for the most part it's
usually pretty split between the teams
they always have like one person that's
undecided and then they'll have like
three on each now i never had a specific
moment where we were tied going to
somewhere but i assume if you're tied
going somewhere you would yourself
choose now it kind of makes no sense
that they would give everyone else a
vote and you only get a vote unless
there's a tie and that's what i'm
assuming if you get a vote if there's a
tie i kind of felt like you should have
got your own vote from the start but it
is pretty nice going around the town
collecting information that you can
persuade your friends into finding out
that you are bugging we don't need to do
this and sometimes they give you actual
life-threatening decisions like what
country you want to visit first or maybe
you know people are demanding your
friend on a wooden stick and they want
you to give him up and you could choose
whether or not you want to do that or
not and then there's some huge decisions
on what country you're going to invade
who you're going to side with all of
these choices are in triangle strategy
and they're very vocal about you have to
convince your friends that what you want
to do is right and after you get enough
of them to agree with you then you'll go
through that path of the story
and sometimes you'll want to do
something but you can't convince all of
your friends that that's the right thing
to do and you end up going the way they
want to but i do feel like in terms of
the story and you know how it goes man
i'm always going to be 100 honest i felt
like the scaling like i said you should
have got your own vote because i felt
like that kind of defeated the purpose
why does everybody get a vote but me and
then i felt like maybe there's a little
bit too much narrative in this game like
when you play games like final fantasy
tactics back in the old days there was a
good amount of fighting over
storytelling and i felt like this game
in particular was way more on one side
than the other and i know look is it bad
no there is a lot of good narrative
focused stuff that goes on here there's
a lot of dialogue and there's a lot of
lore building up that goes into it but
sometimes i felt like i'm sitting there
and i get on my phone while i'm
listening and watching these scenes play
out and i'm just like man i wish i could
just fight something sometimes they will
literally fight in the scenes and i'm
like why couldn't you just let me fight
that person and lose if that was what
was supposed to happen but you know what
i'm gonna go out and live and say that
this isn't really a huge issue with the
game it's just something that i noticed
that they could have fixed a little bit
you know just have a little bit more
battles that's all i think could have
really happened to feel like the balance
is better now
let's talk about gameplay for those of
you that have watched my reviews you
guys know that in my personal opinion
gameplay is king now there are issues
with this gameplay of this game and i
don't think it's anything drastic that
make you look away from this game it's
just stuff that i would perfectly
preference over stuff that i would
normally get on like final fantasy
tactics rafael's another good game that
has this style type of gameplay now
first off let's go over the good stuff
because there's a lot of good stuff
about this game in terms of gameplay you
got unique features that i've really not
seen in any other type of these grid
space games you know i was bringing up
like the elements earlier and the
animations well the reason i feel like
they went extra with that particular
animation and that feature is because
they implemented a feature in this game
to where the elements actually matter so
let's say someone's coming at you on the
field and you need to put a little bit
of a barricade up just to give you
enough time to maybe get your your your
action points up or whatever they call
it on here it's pretty much like every
magic ability has a certain action point
once you get to three you can use that
ability but it takes it down but you
need a barrier right in front of you to
put a little distance between you and
him and make him waste the turn
destroying the barricade before he gets
to you so what do you do you get you a
mage to cast some kind of ice barricade
and what it does is it literally makes
an ice wall on the battlefield
separating you from your opponent now
let's say that you're done using this
barricade you've already got the things
that you need and you've got the amount
of time required that you no longer need
this ice thing blocking you so you can
have another mage cast fire on it and
melt it to a puddle then let's say you
got another major there is one mage that
has all of them for the most part but
let's say you have another major they
got a lightning spell you can actually
electrocute the water and even possibly
stun some of the enemies that comes into
now you don't even have to you know
create this engine i do feel like they
could have did a little bit better in
terms of having majors it's more diverse
so you don't have to like use so many
people to set up these kind of plays but
let's say that there is just like a
giant fountain that's on the battlefield
if you cast lightning on that water in
the fountain and there so happens to be
enemies in that fountain they're going
to not only take damage but risk being
paralyzed for a couple turns and trust
me this really helps and what do i mean
by this helps this game can be hard
sometimes and i mean by that is they
have this thing in here now i know all
the time when you play these type of
games when you start the battlefield and
the enemies are on the battlefield
that's really all you got to deal with
but not in triangle strategy you know
what they do in triangle strategy they
believe in one word and one word only
reinforcements they'll be having people
coming from the left the right straight
you'll be thinking that you're good and
you're about to beat the last couple
people on the map bam five more people
show up sometimes it's very frustrating
and i would say that this is a little
bit on one of those things where they
don't necessarily make it harder they
just put the people on the field to
outnumber you but it doesn't make it bad
i just feel like people are saying that
this game's hard i don't necessarily
agree with that because i feel like
something's hard when you make mechanics
that make that encounter hard not when
you just put more people on the field
for you to fight and that's not
necessarily making something hard just
putting a little bit of fluff on it now
i don't think it's anything you get
upset with because they put a lot of
stuff into this game to help even that
out just a little bit but i just wanted
you guys to let know that like look
sometimes if you don't play this on very
easy or easy because there is easy very
easy normal and hard if you play it on
like very easy you might have a lot
better chance than i played i played it
on normal and there were some times
where i was actually fighting in these
battles and i would barely lose so i
would go you know train a little bit
come come back a little couple levels up
higher and i would normally have easier
time doing these but i want you guys to
know that don't expect a walk in the
park if you play this on normal or
anything higher one thing i want to
point out about triangle strategy is the
ui and whatever combat scenario you're
doing so if you look at the screen the
bottom part that line is how everyone
goes that what let turns they do etc etc
now the cool thing is it's real time so
if i do something like an ability called
delaying strike that a character has it
will show you where they go from what on
that down to what so they'll go from
like let's say they go on turn five but
then i do delaying strike now it will
put up on the map that says they're
gonna go from turn five to turn 15.
they're very informational and i really
enjoy that when it comes to telling me
all the information i need and the
consequences and the perks that could
happen to what i do when you attack
someone it tells you what they're going
to go down to tells you the percentage
that you have of hitting them and if you
go on back shots you'll do more damage
and way bigger chance of critical
attacks and you'll pretty much have a
guaranteed hit if you do any back shots
on them and the crazy part is if you
have someone on each side of someone so
let's say someone's in front of them and
someone's behind them or someone's left
of them and someone's right at them and
they attack while you have someone else
on the other side of that enemy the
person of your ally on the other side of
the enemy is going to hit him again and
this can be used extremely good
especially like i said you get
outnumbered all the time but if you get
really two stealth-like units or maybe
two power units that just do a lot of
damage you get them on each side you can
kill enemies pretty fast and i think
that's the way that the people who made
triangle strategy really expected you to
play this game they wanted you to be
very aggressive and very defensive at
the same time and then you got units
like anna that's an assassination unit
that she kind of does a little bit of
both what i like about her is you can
actually go stealth and you can go
invisible go up a little bit you'll see
someone and what i like to do on there
is either like throw a poison and then
run away or i would like to like throw a
poison and then use her second action
that she gets and put them to sleep and
there's little combos like that that i
feel like set triangle strategy apart
from games like final fantasy tactics
now let's talk about the stuff that i
personally didn't like now they have
equipment on here to where you have to
upgrade your equipment from you know
kind of you need a certain material and
then you can upgrade like your health
from that sword i don't like when you
upgrade attributes on a sword-based
style gameplay i've never liked that and
look technically you are crafting
weapons on here but i don't think it's
really to the point where i would like
i'm very big fan on having a job system
in these type of games in final fantasy
tactics in triangle strategy i like a
job system that i can determine who i
want to be what who i want to be this if
i want you to be a black mage you to be
an archer i feel like they should give
me that option i don't think that's
going to take away from the overall
gameplay of this either and then you
take you to the equipment instead of
like putting some type of ability page
where you actually level up that job
thing because that's what people loved
about the old final fantasy tactics and
this type of gameplay in general is they
like getting some abilities from other
classes and cross
getting skills where you can like be a a
samurai or something you can have dual
welding that you got from the ninja
class and that's kind of like completely
out of this game and i don't know why
they went the direction they did now
look the system works well and i'm not
going to say it doesn't but i do feel
like if they ever make a sequel to this
just let us make our own classes and do
a little bit better job when it comes to
that weapon system i don't want to
upgrade something in my weapon system to
give me more hp that makes no sense to
me do a better job in giving yourself
attributes that doesn't involve a weapon
i i get it that you know maybe it's just
me maybe some of you guys like this
system and i'm not saying it's bad like
i said it did its job i just felt like
they could have done better now let's
talk about the world map on here when i
say world map the lack of a world map
how they pretty much went into this game
is you have something that's called like
an
enchantment now what an enchantment camp
is is pretty much like it's kind of
where your people are set place and
where you are during the time of this
game because you are a nation that's
always going to war with people so you
have this little encampment champ that
you go camp enchantment camp man i'm
just butchering stuff today so you're in
this little camp and you can go to a
merchant you can upgrade your your jobs
which you know i said you can't
necessarily pick what job you want but
you can't upgrade those jobs and that's
really nice to have but like i said i
would have preferred just to pick my job
and to level up that job with some kind
of jaw points or something but you know
i understand that every game can't be
final fantasy tactics and what this game
did is it did set itself apart but i
feel like the biggest disappointment is
the camp in this game because i felt
they use this as a crutch to not really
build a world map and what i mean by
that is they don't really build up these
towns you really go to them once you do
some like generic patrol thing and
sometimes there'll be a merchant there
and it's not even every time there'll be
a merchant there but i would have
preferred to be able to you know click
on the map go to these towns be able to
purchase stuff from the merchants in
these towns and go back and do it again
as long as my relationship with that
nation is good now obviously what they
did here is they wanted to make it a
little bit more casualized to where you
can always get what you need in the
encampment now what the encampment has
is you can buy stuff with this other
currency that you could use in the game
now let's talk about this weird ability
set now for the most part you guys know
that there's always been a way to revive
your allies in these type of games you
know final fantasy tactics the phoenix
downs there's always been a way to do
that now they kind of went away from
that there are abilities to make it to
where like auto life if you go down you
automatically get revived but for the
most part the only way to actually
revive your units is use this weird
currency in the game and it's not just
reviving you can actually give uh you
know battle points to people
you can move people like a magical
portal pops up and they go to another
part of the map where you tell them to
go to you can heal people i don't like
this system at all they make a sequel
get rid of this because i think it kind
of defeats the purpose of items let me
buy stuff that lets me revive people
there's no permadeath in this game for
some reason there should be permadeath
in this type of game to give you that
you only got three to four turns to get
to this person you might lose this
person if you don't get to him you need
to revive you need to heal him i didn't
feel like there was ever a time where i
couldn't just send someone on a suicide
mission to hold people back long enough
for me to build up abilities there was
nothing like that all going on if people
went down they just went back to the
camp and you could revive them with the
special currency but you could only redo
really do that once or twice now there
is a lot of good unique things you can
use with this system but i feel like the
system's kind of flawed for the most
part and i would prefer them just to get
rid of it entirely one of the things
i've always enjoyed doing in these type
of games is the patrol missions where
you go around the map and you fight
these random encounters and you just
level up you kind of fight new ads as
well you fight new creatures new
monsters new actual units in general
that isn't in this game they actually
have something called mental mock
battles and what a mental mock battle is
you go to a person that's in the
encampment enchantment camp and you talk
to them and they're like yo
uh we have these magical fights that you
have in your head pretty much that have
no real consequences on the map on the
game in general at all and that's how
you're going to level up your characters
and you're going to use the same level
up stuff you can get money from it
somehow you get money from doing mental
mock battles i don't understand that i
would have preferred them just to get
rid of this and do regular patrol
missions but that's just me now i think
the camp itself like i said i think it
was a crutch i think it was something
they used to not really enhance a kind
of a world map they didn't really use it
to make unique battles because these
mental mock battles they're all
predetermined so you're always going to
fight the same units in the same
category and for the most part if you
literally do everything you normally do
they will do everything they normally do
so you can really get a good sense on
how these people fight it's nothing
better like i said they it worked it
didn't work i didn't really have a huge
issue with it and i feel like when you
do go about and you you know you get
into a crazy situation where you're
under leveled and you can go back to
these mental mock battles you could just
play a few of them and level up is it
bad no but i do feel like they could
have done better you know get a world
map and have patrol missions where
people just randomly show up but i get
it this is a good alternative i just
felt like they could have did better and
the last thing i really have to talk
about is the music now the music in this
game it's pretty much what you would
expect from these type of games they
always very hit it out the park when it
comes to the music what i like about
this is it really sets the tone you know
you'll be sitting there fighting and it
will get more epic the more people you
lose if enemies shows up on the other
team that's more powerful than you
normally fight like a commander or
something like that the music will
change for that scenario too the music
will change if there's reinforcement
which is like i said this music is going
to change all the time because they'd be
doing random stuff in this game
periodically for the most part and i
don't think you're gonna have any issues
with the music i sure did so i'm sure
you've watched this review and the first
question you have is addict should i buy
this game and that is kind of
complicated now i will say that if you
like these type of games
and you don't really mind putting the 60
down go out there and buy it i think
you're going to be very satisfied with
it it's got a good replay ability
because like i said earlier depending on
what kind of pass you take you get
different characters in the game so you
can replay this game multiple times and
you have to to get certain characters in
the game so that gives it a lot of
replay value and i think that it is
worth the 60 if you like these time to
game now this is a decent game to get
into if you are new to this type of
genre and keep in mind that you know
final fantasy tactics there was a lot of
mechanics on there that made the game
hard but they do casualize this game to
a point now it is hard in terms of
sometimes they'll overwhelm you with
characters but you can do those mental
mock battles over and over again and get
really over leveled so kind of like
balances out a little bit i would say
this is worth the 60 dollars especially
on the switch because it's portable now
i would prefer to wait to something like
steam or the xbox or playstation because
you have better performance in general
over there but if you guys went out and
bought this for a full sixty dollars i
think if you like these type of games
you're gonna be satisfied with this game
it's because look the story is fantastic
the gameplay although it's got its
little issues with me personally it is
still a good solid foundation for game
play on here and the graphics are good
there's nothing really wrong with this
game just a lot of nitpicks for me and
personal things that i was disappointed
with it but i would recommend it i
definitely have to on the switch if you
got a switch and you like those type of
final fantasy tactics games i would
recommend this game it is 60 dollars
like i said i think 40 dollars would
have been a better price point for this
game but who am i to tell the people
with the price they own game at so like
i said it's worth 60 dollars if you like
these type of games but anyway that's
the review for triangle strategy for the
nintendo switch i enjoyed this game a
lot i put like i said 70 hours to do the
game and if it was bad i would have told
you i would have put 15 hours in this
game and i would have been ranting on
twitter about it but i put the whole
playthrough and i even started a second
playthrough you guys have no idea how
hard it is for me to start a game twice
and i did it so that tells you screens
volumes on how replayability this game
is but anyway that's the review guys and
until next time this is lord addict i'm
outta here peace
[Music]